TV, you break our hearts.
We give you hours of our time, and you promise
us a level of consistent bliss, and then you
stab us right in the back.
During the course of almost any great TV show,
you'll find at least one disastrously off-key
episode.
Expect spoilers.
Here are a few TV shows nearly ruined by one
episode.
"The worst episode ever!"
The Walking Dead - Thank You
The world’s most popular zombie show has
enough suspense and desperate relationship
dynamics to keep itself going indefinitely—which
is just one reason why the season six episode,
"Thank You," didn't need to happen like it
did.
Glenn's fake-out-dumpster-death was the first
time the showrunners pulled a deceptive camera
trick.
Even though viewers quickly saw through the
ruse, they were not quick to forgive.
The Walking Dead changed from a straightforward
post-apocalyptic drama into a show that was
comfortable deceiving the audience.
Much to the disappointment of the audience,
similar camera tricks made a controversial
reappearance during the Season 6 finale.
The Simpsons - Natural Born Kissers
Critics often debate the exact point when
the once-amazing Simpsons began to crumble,
though Slate, The New York Post, and plenty
of other cultural pundits all seem to agree
that it was "somewhere during the ninth and
tenth seasons."
So, it’s fair to choose the ninth season
finale as the definitive point where the show
was no longer the series we knew and loved,
since even the official Simpsons website admits
that the popularity of that season was sub-par.
The off-key, overtly sexual theme of “Natural
Born Kissers” could be attributed to the
fact that it was writer Matt Selman's first
crack at the show, but quality control had
already shown signs of slipping.
Viewers started tuning out.
By the time Season 10 premiered, 1.6 million
viewers had already left, making it the lowest-viewed
Simpsons premiere until Season 25.
"Ahhhh ha ha ha ha, oh man that's good!"
Xena: Warrior Princess - Lifeblood
There are hundreds of Xena moments that test
the downward limits of good TV, but viewers
will never forget the laziness of season five's
"Lifeblood."
In an attempt to build an unstoppable trifecta
of ancient adventures geared to modern audiences,
Hercules and Xena producer Rob Tapert created
Amazon High, a two-hour pilot about a modern
girl transported to the time of the original
Amazons.
The network wasn't into it, so Tapert cut
the footage down and crammed it into an episode
of Xena instead, adding ghosts and baby sacrifices.
Despite featuring sci-fi royalty like Selma
Blair, Karl Urban, and Claudia Black, the
sliced-and-diced episode just confused viewers.
Watching the episode was a labor that even
Hercules couldn't have handled.
Doctor Who - Nightmare in Silver
You can easily find a few thousand blog entries
with titles like "Why I Quit Doctor Who,"
or "The Doctor Is Out," and they all have
their own ideas of where Doctor Who jumped
the shark.
Maybe the breaking point is the episode "Nightmare
in Silver."
The Doctor brings some kids to a decommissioned
amusement park—but instead of using his
time machine to bring them back to a time
when it wasn't a dangerous ruin crawling with
Cybermen, they hang out.
Worst babysitter of all time.
The entire episode is a series of unusually
huge plot holes which Radio Times called "execrable,"
"a flop," and "underwhelming,"...which are
polite British code words for "you've just
destroyed everything good in this world."
Twin Peaks - The Man Behind the Glass
David Lynch is allowed a greater weirdness
quotient than almost any other director...
"It was crazy clown time!"
...but "The Man Behind the Glass" during the
second season of the cult classic Twin Peaks
marks the spot where fans started to lose
their enchantment.
For no discernable reason, resident bad boy
James decides to bust out a guitar and sing
a sleepy, ultra-falsetto ballad to a couple
of girls.
"Just youuuuu and I."
The ladies join him in an impromptu singalong,
along with other invisible instruments.
It's the least believable part of a show that
actively incorporated, well, stuff like this...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
TV episodes you almost think ruined your favorite
shows...